[Música]
el papá francisco expresó hoy su dolor
con las 330.000 víctimas de abusos
sexuales que aparecen publicadas en un
informe de la iglesia francesa el día de
hoy y que vendría ocurriendo desde 1950
el papá francisco dijo que su
pensamiento está con las víctimas que
además del gran dolor siente un gran
agradecimiento por la valentía en la
denuncia unos 216.000 jóvenes o menores
de edad habrían sido abusados
sexualmente desde 1950 hasta el año 2020
por curas y otros clérigos y todo esto
en un informe publicado por la comisión
independiente sobre los abusos sexuales
en la iglesia hecha por la conferencia
episcopal francesa para analizar dicha
situación